countries around the world have shut
down to curb the spread of the corona
virus but in South Korea people are
starting to come back out on the streets
starting in late February South Korea
was reporting a sharp increase in
coronavirus cases with over 5,000
infected they were registering some of
the highest numbers of confirmed cases
in the world but then something changed
while cases in most other countries
continued to rise korea's numbers
started leveling off look at how this
curve starts to bend it indicates that
Korea managed to contain the spread of
the virus early on and they were able to
do it because they learned a valuable
lesson a few years ago when they fought
a different coronavirus outbreak in
South Korea the Middle East respiratory
center the death toll on the rise of
ggressive Lee trying to contain the
deadly outbreak the government was
caught completely off guard authorities
are still trying to track down and
isolate anyone who may have been exposed
in 2015 a Korean businessman returning
from the Middle East developed a fever a
cough and eventually pneumonia he went
to several health facilities for a
diagnosis before finally testing
positive for MERS or Middle East
respiratory syndrome caused by a corona
virus by that point his movements had
created a chain of transmission that
became hard for officials to trace they
didn't know who was infected or where
they had been it lasts less than two
months
it was a big penny in South Korea
altogether the virus-infected 186 people
and killed 38 in South Korea the highest
of anywhere outside of the Middle East
the government declared an end to the
outbreak in 2015
citizens can relax the virus no longer
poses a threat but they didn't stop
planning we got many resting on the
importance of the divers tests and we
need basic infection cremation majors
the lessons all came into play when the
next outbreak took hold in the country
on December 31st 2019 China reported the
first case of the corona virus in the
following weeks as the outbreak started
spreading across the world South Korea
only had 30 confirmed cases of the virus
but despite the low numbers health
authorities had already started working
with biotech companies to develop a test
for the novel coronavirus and soon they
had thousands of test kits ready to go
lesson learned from while suffering in
2015 first one is the thymus test is
very essential we developed a lot of
targeted and distribute in every
hospital they prepared for the worst and
the worst quickly followed by late
February the total number of coronavirus
cases rose dramatically crossing 3,000
this made South Korea's outbreak the
largest outside of mainland China and it
all started here in big where a woman
went to the hospital with a fever
because the government had already
equipped hospitals with coronavirus
tests doctors were able to test her she
tested positive and became known as
patient 31 but the testing didn't stop
there while she was sick patient 31 had
gone to a megachurch where she sat with
a congregation of hundreds for more than
an hour
so they traced her movements identified
people she had come into contact with
and then tested those people as well
whether they showed symptoms or not many
of them also tested positive so they
were quickly isolated and treated at
home or at a center and then all the
people they had been in contact with
were traced and tested too this is
called contact tracing it's an approach
that allowed Korea to test over 9,000
people who had been in contact with
someone who had tested positive
after Daegu Korea ramped up testing
around the country private and national
health care systems joined forces to set
up a mostly free testing effort that
includes more than 600 locations could
screen as many as 20,000 people per day
through this system when anyone test
positive the government is able to test
and trace their contacts to continue to
break the transmission chains of the
corona virus on a large scale but that's
just the human to human transmission the
infected person may have moved through
the city touching subway poles and door
handles and South Korea had prepared for
this - after the MERS outbreak when they
weren't able to trace the movements of
the virus Korea changed the law allowing
the government to collect a patient's
data and security footage during an
outbreak
all their steps are logged and then
shared to alert people to stay away from
the path of infection if there is some
confirmed case found near my office they
message by a smartphone there is a
confirmed case near your place he pushes
websites and private apps compile that
information allowing everyone to see
a person with a confirmed case of
coronavirus went to a pharmacy or the
hospital or anywhere else and they'll
know how recently they went to it's a
means of checking the possibility of
infection citizens are checking the
coronavirus locations and are avoiding
going to these areas this information
lets people know if they've crossed
paths with an infected person so they
can go get tested for the virus and
contact tracing starts all over again
tracing people's every move can be
controversial but many in South Korea
prioritize Public Health over privacy in
an outbreak as a result South Korea was
able to test hundreds of thousands of
people more than any other country at
the time and this made it easier for
authorities to see the virus to see
where it's located and where it may be
lurking this ability to find and treat
infected people has allowed Korea to
avoid aggressive lockdowns and it's
helped bend the curve of the outbreak
that started out dangerously steep for
now Korea has turned a corner but they
continue to be prepared we are very
cautious to prevent secondly every day
is kind of a takeover wall it's that
kind of vigilance but a set Korea apart
in the corona virus pandemic but it
wasn't the only place to test people
aggressively Singapore Taiwan and other
neighbors so the benefits of widespread
testing - now countries like Germany and
the UK are starting to implement
aggressive testing and even the US where
the government has failed to provide
adequate testing is now scrambling to
test more people we know that we have to
do more and we continue to accelerate
and testing Korea strategy of contact
tracing might not be easy to replicate
in countries with much larger
populations but the country's success
with widespread testing still offers a
way out for most countries that are
stuck in locked
[Music]